こんにちははじめしたぞとってっ
ブーバー4分ぬーんですけどまぁこれわかんないお前たち
アーサー強いかあぁぬーんですけどっ
強い俺たちで今日は誰が一番寝起きが通過ということでちょっと科学的に入っ
敵ではなかった普通に誰が起きるのが一番強いか寝起きが強いかというのちょっと
バトルしようと思います簡単なやり方でしたのビーチフィット分かります砂浜があって
どう一般で2人パッと浮き上がって席にフラッグのパパで言ってちょっとフォグ価値
っていう僕は
で起きビーチ平口月の今日行ってみようと思います何がすごい
何でも別にそんなに面白くないよ
田近ルーズに俺のね寝起きの強さを知った以下
あんみつ読む寝起き最強4歳とかテンプルにアラームをかけませんスマホでアラームを
かけてちょうど3時間後にせして3時間後にタイマーがたって誰が寝起きで一番その他
今をすぐ止められるかって言うゲームを
まあいたってシンプルなんですけど絶対俺に数はいくん
あらー
も鳴る前に起きちゃったことをすればいい
まあそれでもなんかつよつよすぎるこっちはなんだって勝つんだよと言うとちょっとね
寝起きビーチャーくなってみようと思います
じゃおやすみなさいっぺんは今4:50なんで7:50日7時50分に設定しますこの
時間にアラームが鳴るほどそれをちょっと止めれば勝ちです俺はラーかかりました
ちょうどスターでございます
お休み本当に5分日本はいえ日本は10%程度話だよ
ooooooooooooooooooooo oooo
を
goo
おっ
を
ooooooooooooooooooooo oooo
r
goo
おおおおおおっは
おっショーツスポット深そう
ん
can can
連絡ですいいえ
いいい
ます
しています